pour moi le point positif de cette
gestion de la colline serait d'auray que
justement dans ce gouvernement de
coalition
il ya toute la responsabilité sanitaire
disons qui est déléguée dans les
ministères de santé et de sécurité
sociale
il ya ils sont entre guillemets géré par
le par le parti socialiste espagnol et
après il ya un deuxième bloc fait partie
des compétences en affaires sociales et
donc toutes les aides d'état mis en
place pour éviter que le le ou reçoivent
les citoyens espagnols soient très grand
en brosse tc le réseau comme est en
place sur l'état des dettes sociales
pour éviter que des espagnols se trouve
dans une mauvaise situation
qu'est ce qu'il ya de positif ici c'est
différent de ce que de comment était
géré la crise en 2008 pour la première
fois il ya vraiment des aides sociales
pour les auto entrepreneurs
on a mis en place une sorte de rsa à
l'espagnol s'appelle inglès au minimum
vital et voilà permet aux espagnols
d'avoir une quantité d'argent pour
éviter cette crise économique qui va
sûrement arriver partout dans la planète
on a aussi augmenté le salaire minimal
qui avant était à 600 euros maintenant
il se trouve à 950 euros
je ne trouve pas voilà il ya une sorte
de mesures sociales qui a été mise en
place et qui est quand même très
importante parce que elle elle diffère
de ce qui avait été fait précédemment
dans le pays et qui surtout est aussi
visé à protéger les citoyens et pas
uniquement voilà s'enrichir ou par d
parce qu'on veut avec la santé publique
avec les transports publics
avec ce service public
[Musique]